[Musique]
en belgique cet écran noir pour les
cinémas les salles de spectacles aussi
fermé dès dimanche la mesure vaut
également pour les espaces intérieurs
des parcs d'attraction des parcs
animaliers des activités culturelles
festive et récréative
la sentence est tombée sans vraiment de
préavis hier soir mais les 13 millions
d'habitants a pris par les autorités
locales qu'ils devraient désormais être
en confinement chez eux aucun pays ne
pourra se sentir de la pandémie à coups
de dose de rappel des programmes de
rappel son discernement ont toutes les
chances de prolonger la pandémie plutôt
que d'y mettre fin en détournant les
doses disponibles vers les pays qui ont
déjà des taux de vaccinations élu et
cela offre ainsi au virus plus de
possibilités de se répandre et demi on
dit qu'on a tout fait mais c'est vrai à
l'intérieur de nos frontières mais dans
le monde on n'a rien fait on a dit
encore encore et encore que ce serait
tout le monde ou personne et que tant
qu'on n'aurait pas pris en charge le
virus sur la planète et nous reviendra
assez exactement ce qui vient de se
passer vous demanderez d'avoir beaucoup
de vigilance pendant ces fêtes même si
vous êtes vacciné de vous tester vous
même ou d'aller vous faire tester pour
être sûr que vous n'êtes pas porteurs du
virus avant de retrouver vos proches en
particulier quand ils sont plus âgés un
dernier carton d'autotest on en avait
plié en avance donc aînés reste en
quarantaine mais ça va repartir très
vite histoire des deux trois heures en
attendant une pénurie de tout est enfin
comment ça se fait qu'une pénurie de
tout est jeu serbe vernon qui manque
d'anticipation d'organisation et on va y
venir sûrement mais qui prend en plus
des mesures dangereuses nous a dit
parfois y compris cet été vous êtes plus
dure que les autres on a pris en effet
le pass sanitaire avant la plupart de
pays européens on a été suivie par
beaucoup de pays opère plus de nos culs
de leçon ce virus nous a appris à être
extrêmement modestes et à nous adapter
aux circonstances mais on n'a pas été
dans l'attentisme et dans le laxisme la
suède elle elle a décidé de protéger ses
frontières et réclamons voyageurs en
provenance de l'union européenne de
faire un test est d'avoir un test
négatif comme toujours un manque
d'anticipation
manque d'anticipation peut être lié au
fait qu'ils n'ont pas voulu dire aux
français avant les fêtes de noël ce qui
était en train de se passer mais quand
même une grande inquiétude à la fois
parce que ce variant est en train de
prendre le dessus aujourd'hui par
exemple sur paris le taux d'incidence et
2000 sur cent mille 1000 meilleurs paris
sur paris on a près de 2% de l'ensemble
des jeunes parisiens qui ont été testés
positifs dans les sept derniers jours
donc c'est absolument considérable qu'il
a créés probablement une gravité qui est
qui est faible mais à quel niveau de
baisse de sécurité
selon cette étude un malade atteint par
le vario micro aurait 20 à 25% moins de
risques de se rendre à l'hôpital qu'avec
le variant delta et pour les cas les
plus graves voire même 40 à 45 % de
risques en moins d'être hospitalisée une
nuit ou plus j'ai passé mon premier mac
technique vous voyez devant un tour ou
devant une fraiseuse et ben si et je les
aime quand même pas tout de suite vous
ramenez votre frère
aujourd'hui
croyez pas l'enfer
demain vous êtes là aussi avait une
spéciale avec des produits du terroir
des produits festifs
vous êtes terroir caisse
en chine la découverte d'un fossile
d'embryons dinosaures qui s'apprêtait à
éclore ils datent d'il ya au moins 66
millions d'années un spécimen qui
ressemble un petit oiseau entouré
enroulé dans son 9
444 sapin une ville non dans une seule
et même maison c'est bien le principe
j'ajoute et bien 72000 boules de noël
quarante cinq mille lumières et 300
l'irlande record du monde donc battu
début décembre par un couple d'allemands
qui a manifestement vu des choses très
très bien